[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bonsoir bonsoir à toutes et à tous
Bienvenue c'est sens public votre
rendez-vous quotidien de débat et de
reportages sur Public Sénat la promesse
vous le savez et dans le titre de
l'émission donnée du sens à l'actualité
vous proposez des clés de compréhension
des crises que nous traversons et voici
le sommaire de ce 5 juillet c'est un
signe important du retour au calme les
bus et tramways circuleront normalement
ce soir l'heure est au bilan et à la
compréhension avec un ministre au cœur
des enjeux Gérald Darmanin
nous trouvons pas
comportement de la police
qu'elle doit se réformer et doit aussi
être d'éviter être un bouc émissaire
pour se poser les bonnes questions le
ministre de l'intérieur a été auditionné
cet après-midi par le Sénat quelle leçon
tire-t-il de cette semaine d'émeute que
propose les principaux partis politiques
pour mettre fin aux violences urbaines
en en débat avec trois sénateurs dans
une minute et puis pour notre second
thème volontairement décalé de
l'actualité du jour je vous propose un
gros plan sur les complotistes du climat
ils sont de plus en plus nombreux en
France à rejoindre ses bataillons de
climato-sceptiques qui refusent la
réalité scientifique le réchauffement
climatique est causé par l'activité
humaine on décortique le discours les
motivations économiques parfois
politiques de ces marchands de doutes
dans trois quarts d'heure mais d'abord
Gérald Darmanin face aux questions des
sénateurs les points les plus saillants
choisis par Jérôme Rabier
le temps était contraint et les
questions des sénateurs nombreuses pour
cette audition du ministre de
l'Intérieur l'occasion pour Gérald de
Darmanin de dresser un bilan des émeutes
des derniers jours
12031 véhicules incendiés
2508 bâtiments incendie ou dégradés dont
273 bâtiments qui appartiennent aux
forces de l'orgue 105 mairies incendie
ou dégradées 168 écoles on fait l'objet
d'attaque quelle qu'elle soit les
services de la police nationale
gendarmerie ont procédé à 3500 5
interpellations dont 1373 dans la seule
zone de la préfecture de police
c'est-à-dire Paris et sa petite couronne
après ce bilan chiffré c'est sur le
profil des interpellés que le ministre
soulignons creux des difficultés mais
une sociologie qui interroge la
sociologie des délinquants des émeutiers
interrogent sur ces 3500 interpellations
j'ai l'occasion de le dire la moyenne
d'âge entre 17 et 18 ans comme j'ai dit
tout à l'heure à ma connaissance 60%
une personne que nous avons interpellé
n'ont pas de casier judiciaire et ne
sont pas connus des services de police
interroger notamment sur les rapports
police population le ministre n'a pas
fait d'annonces nouvelles même si la
concédé qu'il fallait mieux faire dans
de nombreux domaines que je croise le
bilan de jardin les propositions des
principaux partis pour mettre fin à
trouver des solutions face à ces
violences urbaines on en débat avec
François bonhomme bonsoir bienvenue vous
êtes sénateur LR du Tarn-et-Garonne Ian
chanterelle sénateur PSD Français de
l'étranger et François Patriat bonsoir
sénateur de la Côte d'Or président du
groupe Renaissance au Sénat Mathieu
croissanto bonsoir Mathieu et politique
je vous pose de réécouter un autre
extrait on en a eu quelques-uns de cette
audition de Gérald Darmanin ce moment où
le ministre de l'Intérieur rend hommage
aux forces de l'ordre
du GIGN de la Berry ou des pelotons de
la gare de républicaine ont été
mobilisés dans toutes les villes de
France et on procédé à ces très
nombreuses interpellations je crois dans
des conditions conformes à la loi et à
la déontologie et aux principes de
proportionnalité que je leur ai demandé
même s'il peut y avoir des moments
dramatiques et évidemment on entend ici
ou là le fait que cela puisse exister il
n'y a à ma connaissance que 10 saisit de
l'IGPN ou de l'iggn dans des cas
particuliers pour l'instant pour lequel
je n'ai que très peu d'informations et
pour le cas d'ailleurs des enquêtes
judiciaires te sont ouvertes François
bonhomme comment vous jugez vous évaluez
l'action du ministre de Gérald Darmanin
depuis une semaine moi sur le plan du
maintien de l'ordre et de la tentative
de retour à la paix civile je n'ai rien
à ajouter à ce qui a été fait je crois
que mission intérieur a joué pleinement
son rôle je crois simplement que les
questions qui nous occupent pour
l'avenir se situent ailleurs que dans
son ministère d'accord donc on va on va
entrer de nombreuses et il a eu
l'occasion d'y répondre évidemment aussi
cet après-midi il y a de chanter on
vient de l'entendre le ministre de
l'Intérieur soutient la police il est
dans son rôle vous attendiez autre chose
de sa part malheureusement non pour une
raison simple c'est que un ministre de
l'Intérieur d'ailleurs dans d'autres
pays moi je trouve ça beaucoup plus
intéressant on appelle ça un ministre de
la Sécurité publique elle n'est pas
uniquement le chef de la police le
problème en France c'est qu'on assiste
le plus plusieurs années à une cogestion
du ministre de l'intérieur avec les
syndicats de police un ministre de
l'Intérieur il y a le ministre de la
Sécurité publique n'est pas juste le
chef entre guillemets de la police et ça
c'est particulièrement grave parce qu'il
y a eu plusieurs événements qui je pense
pour tout républicain devrait choquer
c'est les communiquer deux syndicats de
police qui dans d'autres pays je peux
vous le dire ils m'ont dit les ont plus
qu'interpeller disent que la France
c'est un pays démocratique où on accepte
des syndicats de police parlent de
nuisibles de guerre et menaces
clairement le gouvernement que si il
prend pas les mesures que les syndicats
considèrent des mesures de de violence
aussi quelque part et bah il y aura une
forme de sédition et ça c'est
particulièrement grave parce que quand
on interroge le ministre à partir
qu'est-ce qui pose problème de dire
parce que c'est des faits moi j'ai vécu
plus de 30 ans en banlieue j'ai été
témoin de discrimination de la part de
la police j'ai beaucoup de témoignages
par rapport à ça quel est l'honneur
justement d'un ministre de l'Intérieur
de reconnaître ça et de dire
effectivement c'est condamnable on ne
peut pas accepter ça dans une police
républicaine et je vais tout faire pour
l'éradiquer qu'est-ce qu'il y a eu
là-dessus rien zéro il n'a pas dit un
seul mot alors que la mèche qui a
déclenché tout ça c'est quand même la
mort d'un jeune ou des policiers mentez
jusqu'à ce qu'on ait des images et je
peux vous dire que j'étais avec un haut
déniataire canadien il m'a dit qu'il
était particulièrement choqué que ça n'a
fait aucune histoire en France que des
policiers montent mentent et ont aimé il
a dit au Canada ça aurait pas tenu une
journée que déjà ils auraient été tous
mis à pied et que le ministre avait dû
rendre des comptes sur ces éléments là
François Patriot ça n'a pas été fait
dans votre
réponse là-dessus ce que je retiens ce
que je synthétise un ministre de
l'Intérieur qui est trop au soutien de
ces troupes et notamment des syndicats
même quand il déraps je synthétise
d'abord les événements dans les cités
sont toujours des événements dramatiques
quand il y a comme ça à soulèvement et à
des choses deuxièmement on a vu qu'en
2005 ils ont duré pratiquement trois
semaines personne ne savait aujourd'hui
au bout de la quatrième nuit commence à
allait se passer la réponse du
gouvernement elle a été mesurée graduée
la main n'a pas trembler on a évité le
couvre-feu on a évité l'état d'urgence
qui troublait toutes les populations par
ailleurs et l'ordre est revenu je dis
pas bonjour momentanément problème n'est
pas seulement de savoir si un syndicat a
des failli par un communiqué pour le
savoir est-ce qu'aujourd'hui est-ce
qu'il faut réformer la police en fait
c'est la question qu'on a qu'on aurait
pu se poser au premier soir qui a été
qui a été balayé par les nuits d'émeutes
et qui peut se reposer maintenant ce que
je trouve demander la position du
ministre de l'Intérieur que le peu que
le ministère je dis à Yann chanterelle
que non contrairement à ce qu'il dit la
condamné il est encore une tout à
l'heure il a dit qu'il était en
désaccord et qu'il l'a dit il a dit
publiquement il avait déjà dit qui
condamnait mais il a dit aussi dans ce
France c'est pas le ministre qui
contrôle les communiquer des syndicats
ou alors on serait dans un autre dans un
autre dans un autre pays par ailleurs
mais imaginez imaginez que dans ces
conditions un mini sur ne soit pas en
soutien des pompiers des mers des forces
de l'ordre mais dans quelle situation
serait-on aujourd'hui non mais où est-ce
qu'on en serait je veux donc globalement
il se peut que dans la police il y a des
conduites qui se donnent à reproches
qu'il y ait des difficultés je crois que
je l'entends bien tout le monde le dit
aujourd'hui mais globalement je pense
que les forces de l'ordre et l'action de
Gérald Darmanin ont été à la hauteur de
l'événement je vous vois acquiescer aux
propos de François naturellement parce
que le sujet principal c'est vraiment le
soutien
total que l'on doit en offre de sécurité
policier gendarmes et sapeurs-pompiers
je le rappelle qui ont été aussi
attaqués et ciblés voilà c'est le
premier sujet c'est que quand la
question d'une aussi fondamentale que
celle de du retour à l'ordre est posé on
s'appuie et ça se traduit par une
confiance total dans l'effort de
sécurité après parce que maintenant on
l'espère d'ailleurs que le calme est
revenu même si il est relatif et même si
on est prudent est-ce que c'est le
moment de se reposer ces questions la
première question c'est les causes de
cette de cette déferlement de violence
on a eu quand même à partir d'un fait
divers tragique une situation vraiment
où c'était à feu à 100 dans 140 villes
de France non mais c'est ça la question
alors comment ça pu advenir comment on a
pu en arriver là là ça pose vraiment à
la question de notre analyse sur le
terreau social parce que un phénomène
nouveau quand même c'est la jeunesse des
émeutiers là plus de 50% des
arrestations ont porté sur des moins de
17 ans des jeunes totalement des
culturés déstructurées hyper connectés
réseaux sociaux en permanence qui crée
quand même un facteur d'effet de groupe
de terrible voilà avec des jeunes qui
attaquent des centres sociaux des
biotechs c'est pas pour aller se
précipiter sur la lecture c'est vraiment
pour détruire pour détruire donc comment
on arrive à une panne de la population
une panne de la jeunesse un espèce qui
est qui arrive à cette extrémité de
déferlement de violence pour manifester
une colère la colère encore une fois
n'excuse pas tout en espèce de rien du
tout quand vous dites des culturez ça
veut dire quoi pour vous mais des
cultures c'est à dire qu'il manque de
repères c'est clair non mais regardez
les programmes scolaires on leur apprend
les logs durable alors on va prendre
tout un tas de deux choses mais ce qui
forme la vie l'autonomie d'un citoyen
l'autonomie de jugement c'est quand même
c'est quand même une scolarité où on a
les savoirs fondamentaux on en parle
souvent mais on voit bien ce que ça
produit quand on est sorti de du système
scolaire et quand on est à la marge
quand et parfois des scolarisé alors ce
matin sur France Info Bruno Retailleau
le président du groupe LR au Sénat s'en
est pris à Gérald Darmanin notamment sur
la question du lien entre émeutes et
immigration on écoute Bruno Retailleau
que j'entends Gérald Darmanin hier à
l'Assemblée nationale dire qu'il y a pas
de lien
entre ces événements et les migration
bien sûr que si mais 90% des mais c'est
pas la question c'est pas la questionner
et j'ai questionné de nombreux mères
tous vous disent que c'est dans les
quartiers justement où il y a des
ghettos migratoires certes ce sont des
Français mais ce sont des Français par
leur identité et malheureusement pour la
deuxième la troisième génération il y a
comme une sorte de régression vers les
origines vers les origines ethniques
comment vous réagissez à ces propos de
Bruno retailleux est-ce que c'est une
réalité peut-être difficile à admettre
sur laquelle il faut placer des mots ou
alors une forme d'instrumentalisation de
sa part ces propos une honneur vraiment
pas monsieur Retailleau je pense que la
droite est dans un puissant fond dans
une forme de course à l'échalote avec
l'extrême droite de plus plusieurs
années il en fait encore une fois de
plus l'illustration honteuse la
République en ont plus que le nom de
plus en plus et en fait qu'est-ce qui
veut dire par là il y aurait des
différences des Français différents des
autres moi je suis binational je ne suis
pas un français comme un autre c'est ça
qui veut dire ou alors ça dépend de quel
binosité on parle il veut faire le tri
entre les ressortissants français il y a
des ressortissants français qui sont
plus on va les trier c'est ça qui
souhaite faire il faut être un peu
sérieux à un moment donné on parle de
républicain donc ces gens-là sont pas
sérieux on parle d'apaisement d'ailleurs
nos mères étaient aussi en première
ligne nos élus par rapport à ça ce ne
sont pas des paroles qui apaisent un
pays ce qui vient de tenir comme propos
ça n'est pas seule personne qui permet
l'ordre dans le pays et d'apaiser le
pays c'est des propos justement qui
enflamment alors votre réponse en soit
vous reprenez les propos de
l'apaisement n'empêche doit pas empêcher
le déni le déni c'est quand même devoir
que ces jeunes s'en repèrent
désinhibé avec un sentiment d'impunité
comment on a pu en arriver là ça c'est
la question fondamentale de l'école
parce que c'est vraiment c'est des
générations nouvelles qui arrivent qui
l'ont connu que le téléphone portable ne
doit pas être mis en cause à tout propos
mais là là on a vraiment une situation
qui a créé un phénomène de viecturation
majeure qui doit nous interroger les
générations qui arrivent mais en pardon
je vais reposer la question allez-y
Mathieu
vers les origines ça veut dire que les
origines de ces gens-là sont désinhibés
sans repères et agressif par nature
c'est ça que ça veut dire il peut y
avoir plusieurs causes figurines la
question très précise Bruno retaillod
dit en gros on sait pas des des Français
parce que la troisième génération en
fait il régresse
la cause d'une migration subit et non
maîtrisée est un facteur aggravant c'est
évident ça c'est un facteur indéniable
que c'est pas un élément de
structuration sociale que d'avoir d'être
sans papier d'être migrants et d'être
sans contrôle
en plusieurs types de réalité mais dans
ces facteurs là il y a ce type de
réalité il faut quand même pas être dans
les déminéralité je pense que on n'a pas
envie d'entendre des choses désagréables
certes mais ce qui s'est passé la
gravité de ce qui s'est passé doit nous
obliger à poser des questions y compris
quand elles sont douloureuses et vous
pensez que braquer une boutique Lacoste
ou une boutique de téléphone mobile
c'est un truc d'immigré
mais vous regardez on va analyser
profondément le profil des émeutiers il
y a tout un tas de profils mais il y
aura quand même des migration pour vous
ça le pillage de boutique de
centre-ville mais c'est il y a un fait
quelque chose en fait de très migré qui
fait convaincre il y a 5 ans de vie qui
ont été touchées donc on va faire
l'analyse à froid de manière sereine
mais on sait déjà de manière assez
évidente que il y a dans ces facteurs
multifactoriels il y a cet élément là
enfin je veux dire on peut pas non plus
nier qui a de cette dimension là qui
rentre dans la dans l'explication
comment on a pu arriver à se déferlement
de violence la réponse de Gérald
Darmanin cet après-midi devant la
sénateur la commission des lois c'était
cette explication identitaire elle est
erronée c'est une réponse trop facile
François Patriot à votre avis je suis
plutôt une position intermédiaire entre
ce que j'ai bien entendu d'abord je
pense que dans un moment comme ça leur
n'est pas au polémique elle est plutôt
aux questions à l'analyse et un peu de
recul première chose deuxième chose je
trouve que le président
a bien
dénommé cette situation il a dit nous
sommes dans un processus de
décibilisation
dire que dire que le phénomène
migratoire est le lie avec l'homme je
pense que c'est une erreur aussi la
preuve en est je la cite est tout à
l'heure avec d'autres parlementaires des
villes en Côte-d'Or la ville de Beaune
il n'y a pas un problème il y a pas un
problème de d'immigration pas de
problème à bonnes imaginez ville de
20000 habitants il n'y a pas de présence
mais lequel le Commissariat a été
attaqué
les boulangeries ont été attaqués
boutiques au théâté c'est paliers ou
phénomène migratoire voilà donc il y a
par contre ce que veut dire Retailleau
je pense que peut-être qu'il dit ce qui
veut dire je crois comprendre c'est que
les premières générations d'immigrés
sont arrivées en France
avait moins de problèmes de sécurité
juridique que non non les générations
aujourd'hui la troisième génération
c'est une génération aujourd'hui se
retrouve dans des conditions sociales
qui peuvent apparaître comme des excuses
aujourd'hui je l'entends bien je crois
que c'est ce que veut dire pour le
moteur on peut dire les choses
différentes est-ce que on est face à
évidemment pas d'amalgame ou de
généralisation mais certains jeunes de
cette génération qui ont un sentiment
d'appartenance nationale qui est dégradé
est-ce qu'on peut dire ça comme ça à
votre avis avoir une forme de
ressentiment quand vous avez ce type de
de discours vous faites comprendre à une
partie de la population qui ne sont pas
Français à part entière aussi c'est ça
qu'il aurait renvoyé dans ce genre de
discours je suis désolé oui et ça peut
être aussi on va parler de la
responsabilité des parents
c'est pas seulement le discours
politique qui interroge même vos propres
identité et votre présence sur le
territoire français je vous ai dit que
j'avais des témoignages je connais des
personnes qui a fait un calcul c'est un
ami qui était venu étudier qui est
franco-tunisien à Sciences Po à Paris il
m'a dit j'ai fait le décompte en une
année j'ai été contrôlé 300 fois pour
aucune raison avec des brimades on
mettait mon sac à l'envers j'ai un autre
une autre personne que je connais un
policier a ouvert mon sac m'a dit où
as-tu volé cette écharpe il l'avait pas
volé sa mère l'avait offert il lui a dit
bah maintenant c'est à moi allez porter
plainte auprès des policiers quand vous
vivez en permanence des brimades des
contrôles sans aucune raison il y a des
pays on appelle ça du profilage racial
qu'est-ce que dans une démocratie
je pense que c'est quand même acceptable
de se dire qu'est-ce qui autorise des
policiers à contrôler des personnes sans
raison on contrôle des personnes dans
plein de pays démocratiques qui font des
délits elles font des bruits elles font
elles font du vol comme être des délits
on les contrôle et on les sanctionne par
contre des personnes qui ne commettent
aucun délites à force de les contrôler
constamment 300 fois par année comme la
personne que je vous ai évoqué c'est
quoi le délit qui est insinué c'est leur
présence même qui posent problème dans
l'espace public c'est ça que vous
contrôlez vous n'avez rien à faire ici
c'est ça qui est renvoyait donc si on
veut s'attaquer aux problèmes majeurs et
effectivement il y en a et qui plus est
pour préserver les policiers qui font
bien leur travail et qui sont également
victimes de ces personnes là il faut une
meilleure formation de nos policiers il
faut également l'IGPN c'est une
catastrophe quand vous voyez que le
ministre de tutelle de l'IGPN c'est
Monsieur Darmanin qui cogère la police
avec les syndicats de police
automatiquement il y a un vrai problème
de confiance même auprès de l'IGPN donc
ça il faut des réformes fortes et il
faut pas des réformes évidemment que sur
la police on pourra peut-être en parler
parce que la politique de la ville on
dit qu'il y a eu des milliards de
versets vaste blague alors c'est une
pure communication alors je voudrais
vous parler de la formation des
policiers tiens en écoute un autre
extrait elle était passionnant de cette
audition de du ministre de l'Intérieur
Gérald Darmanin devant les sénateurs ce
mercredi après midi oui
un travail difficile de formation des
policiers oui vous avez raison Madame la
Gontrie trois tyran administratifs c'est
pas assez notamment les tirs dit en
mouvement parce que c'est ça la
difficulté quand je suis arrivé au
ministère de l'Intérieur la gaubrerie
60% des policiers seulement vers leurs
trois tirs administratifs c'est leur
administration qui est responsable de
leur sécurité et la première chose que
fait l'igpet de l'IGN c'est de vérifier
que le policier a fait trois tirs
administratifs et s'il n'a pas fait il
le sanctionne mais c'est pas lui qui
refuse de faire toiture administratif
c'est qu'il y a pas assez de stands de
tir c'est qu'il y a pas assez de temps
pour la formation c'est nous les
employeurs de ces policiers qui sont
responsables vous avez raison il faut
largement améliorer ça je crois que la
loi que vous avez votée nous permet de
le faire
tu veux votre analyse d'un point de vue
politique comment
Gérald Darmanin sort de cette crise mais
si on en juge en termes de résultats on
l'a dit il en sort plutôt renforcé il
suffit d'imaginer les réactions ou les
commentaires si la crise perdurer pour
le mesurer après 4000 violences l'ordre
de CAM sont progressivement revenus même
si pendant une nuit la police a semblé
perdre le contrôle de la situation et
alors qu'en 2005 les émeutes avaient
duré trois semaines il y a eu un retard
à l'allumage mais si la France a été à
feu le pire a été évité et donc voilà
pour l'instant j'ai eu bien pour
l'instant parce qu'il faut être prudent
le calme et l'ordre sont revenus dès le
mercredi soir le miso intérieur est fait
passer les consignes extrêmement clairs
au policiers sur le terrain fermeté
d'accord mais évitez tout comportement
inadapté et pas se lancer dans des
opérations
qui attiseraient les tensions type des
contrôles de points de ville ou des
choses comme ça il a pas hésité à mettre
le paquet en terme d'effectif affichant
le chiffre impressionnant et aussi
vérifiable de 45000 gendarmes et
policiers unités d'élite comprise il n'a
pas à l'état d'urgence il l'a souligné
bref tout ça sur le volet opérationnel
montre que ça quand même plutôt
fonctionné sur la communication sur la
communication a fait preuve d'une grande
souplesse parce que vous vous souvenez
il a d'abord pleuré les familles de
policiers victimes d'accidents liés à
des refus d'obtempérer ça c'était le
mardi de la semaine dernière avant
d'assurer la famille de Naël de son
soutien et d'exiger la vérité ça c'était
mercredi puis de réenfiler son costume
de premier flic de France dès le
lendemain et de prôner la fermeté dans
tout ses déplacements il a fait du Sarko
en tampon séjour-ci en référence à son
illustre précédeur place Beauvau il a
fait plutôt mieux que Sarko qu'en 2005
et puis surtout il a fait du Sarko sans
provoque ce qui avait que Gérald
Darmanin était pas forcément gagné sur
le papier il a pas oublié de faire de la
politique aussi non alors il y a plus
appuyer sur le soutien et l'Amicale
pression du président de la République
quand même qui demandait des résultats
rapides mais aussi sur ce qui est plus
rare sur une fermeté partagée avec son
collègue garde des sceaux toujours une
rivalité ministère de l'Intérieur mise à
la justice là Eric Dupont-Moretti a été
sur la même ligne prudent je le disais
il a plutôt
éviter les dérapages verbaux Gérald
Darmanin les heures dérapages dont il
est coutumiers mais il a pas hésité à
lâcher ses coups contre ses bêtes noires
la France insoumise d'abord vous n'êtes
pas des révolutionnaires vous êtes des
petits révoltés ou le rassemblement
national auquel il a rappelé que nous
sommes nombreux ici à être issus des
quartiers à être issus du migration et à
notre pays voir à se taper les deux
réunis nous ne voulons ni de l'année des
policiers aux uns ni de l'un des
étrangers aux autres mais nous voulons
l'amour de la République et jouer sur du
courage d'une certaine manière il a donc
marqué des points je disais mais mais
attention la crise a aussi sérieusement
bousculée son agenda et ouvert devant
lui des chantiers qui vont être très
compliqué d'abord son projet de loi
immigration reste en chantier et il va
pas être évident à piloter n'y sauvent
pas non plus être évident de trouver
forcément une majorité quant à la
nécessaire réflexion sur la relation
entre la police et la jeunesse entre la
police et une partie de la population va
rentrer de police et l'ensemble des
Français ça ça ne pourra pas être évité
ou enterré et ça ça sera très compliqué
alors justement je vous propose de
réagir maintenant on ouvre un thème
important vous l'avez un peu évoqué mais
on va se concentrer dessus dans ce débat
sur euh puisqu'on on est là pour aussi
examiner les propositions des différents
partis politiques une proposition de la
France insoumise revenir sur la loi
Cazeneuve de 2017 je vous le rappelle
qui est tendait aux policiers les mêmes
règles d'usage des armes que les
gendarmes notamment en cas de refus
d'obtempérer ce texte doit-il être revu
et corrigé Yann Chanel alors comme tout
parlementaire on évalue les lois si
elles sont pas bonnes il faut les
changer donc ça moi j'ai aucun tabou qui
que ce soit qui est l'auteur de loi si
elles sont mauvaises il faut les changer
donc il faut savoir
il faut absolument revenir dessus parce
que on voit effectivement dans la
période qui a suivi une augmentation de
de de tir aval à balles réel et une
augmentation aussi des refus
d'obtempérer cette refus cette
augmentation est également valable en
gendarmerie mais ça a fait moins de
morts donc ça questionne aussi par
rapport à ce qui ce qui a mis en place
donc aucun problème pour l'évaluer il
faut qu'on regarde bien les choses en
détail et si effectivement on s'aperçoit
que ça amène à des dérives il faut
effectivement le changer François
Patriat
au-delà bon il y a cette proposition de
la France insoumise au-delà de la de ses
propositions le contenu des prises de
parole des leaders de la France
insoumise depuis une semaine ça vous
choque sur ce sujet moi je ne suis pas
d'accord de d'abord je partais à la
majorité qui a soutenu cette décision on
rappelle qu'à l'époque j'allais soutenue
et qu'aujourd'hui je pense que l'aligner
la police sur la gendarmerie c'est une
bonne chose mais il faut pas comparer
les résultats au nombre de tirs parce
que la gendarmerie est le perd surtout
en zone rurale alors que la police
intervient en zone urbaine où il y a
beaucoup plus de faits de violence de
délinquance quoi zone rurale donc c'est
normal qui est plus mais en admettant
les choses que si jamais alors que le
nom de refus d'obtenterré est passé à
15000 16000 enfin je connais pas le
chiffre exact multiplié par des dizaines
et des centaines aujourd'hui dans le
même temps le nombre de tirs n'a pas
augmenté par ailleurs et que si il y a
il a augmenté la première année qui a
suivi la loi et ensuite ça s'est plutôt
stabilisé mais donc non mais si
aujourd'hui imaginez dans le contexte
actuel donner un signal à la police de
ce genre de main de ne pas pouvoir tirer
j'imagine que d'abord les forces de
l'ordre mais aussi même la population
son émouvant alors pas de nom je pense
là encore j'essaie d'être modéré je
pense que si le texte est flou s'il y a
des interprétations qui ne sont pas bien
comprises on me dit qu'il est pas très
bien compris j'ai vu un avocat des
syndicats de police qui disait que le
texte pouvait être revu je pense que si
le texte doit être revu sur l'autre sur
la forme je pense que sur le fond on
doit le garder être précis qu'est-ce que
vous seriez prêt à revoir sur ce texte
c'est le fameux alinéa 4 qui autorise
les tirs en cas de recherche
je crois qu'il y a du Fou sur les
conditions d'utilisation de l'arbre
immobilier autrement que par l'usage des
armes des véhicules dont les conducteurs
n'ont pas à l'ordre d'arrêt et dont les
occupants sont susceptibles de perpétrer
dans leur fuite des attentes à leur vie
alors intégrité physique ou à celle
d'autrui là ils peuvent tirer qu'est-ce
que vous changeriez à ça
en l'occurrence mais
il y a aussi ce qu'on en fait il y a les
textes et ce qui est en a été fait on a
vu et ça vous l'avait dit vous-même une
augmentation aussi des morts dans le
cadre de refus d'entre vous serez qui
n'était pas le cas il faut effectivement
là c'était pas le cas pour le cas qui
qu'on a observé que la personne soit en
danger pour qu'elle puisse pour qu'elle
puisse éventuellement la question c'est
est-ce que c'est bon voilà des un
policier qui voilà
péter les plombs on va reprendre un
terme qui vous a évalu une critique de
la porte-parole de la police sur ce
plateau mais je le reprends à mon compte
ouais et si c'est ça est-ce que ça
mérite de remettre en cause l'ensemble
du texte quoi c'est ça la vraie question
mais d'où le fait c'est ce que je vous
ai dit au départ d'évaluer en détail les
choses d'expertiser et de regarder
effectivement si c'est ça d'ailleurs il
y avait déjà à l'époque j'ai regardé les
débats en 2016-2017 moi j'étais pas élu
c'était pas parlementaire mais il y
avait beaucoup d'associations d'ailleurs
qui disait que ça pouvait amener à ça il
y a eu
qui avait été émise avant même alors
c'était passé un peu inaperçu parce que
c'était en 2017 en pleine campagne
présidentielle personne n'a vu passer ça
mais il y avait beaucoup d'alerte et
d'ailleurs l'époque ça a été adopté
après un fait divers data contre des
policiers à Viry à Viry-Châtillon et ça
a été fait dans la foulée sur une
demande d'ailleurs des syndicats donc je
pense que ça il faut jamais légiférer
dans ce genre de domaine sur le coup de
l'émotion je pense que c'est ça qui peut
être dangereux être en responsabilité
des hommes d'État et vous l'avez très
bien dit tout à l'heure c'est de pouvoir
regarder les choses à froid c'est ce
qu'il faut faire également avec ça pour
regarder les choses à faire parce que là
c'est à chaud pour éventuellement
regarder ceux qui ne va pas pour
l'instant on n'a pas exactement le
passage du texte il faudrait qu'il
faudrait changer est-ce que ce serait
affaiblir la police en ce moment que de
revenir sur cette sur cette loi 2017 je
rappelle que cette loi de février 2017
éteint les cas de légitime défense alors
maintenant ceux qui l'ont voté enfin
selon qu'ils ont proposé à savoir
à l'époque votée par Olivier fork il
faut le rappeler maintenant étant sont
en train de le remettre en cause parce
qu'ils ont peur de d'être quelque part
mis en concurrence avec elle et les
filles de se détacher je crois que cette
loi elle était vraiment un point
d'équilibre il se fait que nos forces de
l'ordre sont régulièrement en situation
de porter atteinte à leur vie donc on a
trouvé un texte qui fixe un cadre
d'accord après l'application
individuelle c'est tout le travail de
l'enquête qui va être fait pour savoir
si les conditions requises ont été
respectées mais la formulation et
l'écriture du texte en espèces je vois
mal comment on peut revenir derrière non
la vraie question c'est surtout adresser
un message malgré tout de confiance no
fort de l'ordre c'est quand même faut
voir ce que c'est qu'aujourd'hui une vie
de policiers de gendarmes qui est appelé
sur ces heures supplémentaires à
maintenir l'ordre dans ces conditions en
mettant en jeu leur vie et je peux vous
dire que les critiques que j'entends de
certaines associations qui parle de de
qui de racisme de discrimination
d'insuffisance de Poitiers de la ville
ça ne crée pas d'évocations à entrer
dans gendarmerie ou dans la police ça je
crois vraiment que c'est d'ailleurs
c'est le paradoxal c'est que on regrette
le manque de formation en espèces en
diminué on a diminué sous case neuve
puis sous Castaner qui a remonté le
temps de formation il faut quand même le
rendre justice à cela et c'est quand
même paradoxal donc d'un côté de de
mettre la suspicion et après de
s'étonner qu'on a des difficultés de
recrutement là il y a quand même un
paradoxe que je m'explique mal allez on
ouvre un autre chapitre avec une autre
proposition cette fois-ci elle vient de
l'autre côté de l'échiquier du
rassemblement national à l'Assemblée le
parti de Marine Le Pen veut supprimer
l'excuse de minorité voilà la
proposition qui a été faite je cite les
mineurs capables de discernement doivent
être pénalement responsables des crimes
délits ou contraventions dont ils ont
été reconnus coupables François patrietz
que c'est une solution pour vous non je
pense pas que tu es sûr que ce que je ce
que je constate c'est qu'il y a des
mineurs en l'occurrence qui pourra trop
grand nombre ont été arrêtés des enfants
de 12 ans 12 ans 12 ans imaginez un peu
donc eux on peut pas dire qu'ils aient
été soumis à le discrimination parce que
eux ils sont pas contrôlés tous les
jours il y a pas de contrôle officiel
sur demande pas les papiers tous les
jours qu'est-ce qui vous fait penser ça
qu'est-ce qu'il faut vous dire ça parce
que je pense que j'ai pas enfin j'ai
jamais entendu dire que que les que les
policiers faisaient des contrôles sur
des jeunes de 10 ans 12 ans on peut pas
se référer à ce qu'on vous a dit il y a
des études très claires qui sont faites
sur le sujet je peux même vous les
partager si vous avez même vous avez
même l'ONU qui a condamné la France à
plusieurs reprises en général c'est pas
des pays démocratiques sur ces questions
là qui sont qui sont tensées par l'ONU
ça devrait minimalement nous faire
réfléchir au moins les pays et le
fantasy mais est-ce que vous est-ce que
vous reconnaissez quand même qu'il y a
des discriminations de la part de la
police oui ou non je pense qu'il y a des
discriminations et qui disent qu'il
partout dans ce pays
le reconnaître déjà c'est important qui
dépose cette semaine au Parlement une
loi sur les discriminations que nous
reprendrons dans notre niche j'espère
très vite parce que c'est important
aujourd'hui c'est pour l'embauche c'est
pour les tas de choses absolument il y a
aujourd'hui un texte discrimination
qu'on comprend aujourd'hui alors pour
les jeunes je pense d'abord les jeunes
nous avons déjà travaillé sur la justice
des mineurs on a raccourci maintenant
terrible grâce à l'action du garde des
eaux du gouvernement le délai de
traitement des mineurs les mineurs
aujourd'hui sont traités forcément à
part on va pas aujourd'hui dire qu'il y
a pas de délit parce qu'on est mineur
d'ailleurs il y a des mineurs qui ont
commis des crimes vous avez vu quand il
y a mineur qui a tué son professeur il
était mineur il était immédiatement
incarcéré donc c'est déjà fait
aujourd'hui c'est déjà dans les fêtes
aujourd'hui pour les délires voilà
bon est-ce qu'il faut une justice
particulière pour les mineurs finalement
c'est ça la question posée par le
rassemblement national est-ce qu'il faut
est-ce qu'il faut les juger différemment
ou est-ce que à l'aune de la violence de
ces derniers jours finalement il faut
filmer
la question comment on les juge c'est
qu'un régime particulier pour les
mineurs mais ce qui paradoxal ce qui est
étonnant en tout cas
c'est que avant d'en arriver à cette
question de la responsabilité pénale
ne creuse pas la question de la
responsabilité parentale parce que là
quand même le premier niveau
relationnel avec un enfant c'est les
parents qui doivent l'assurer
l'éducation et là je veux dire quand on
prend le cas d'espèce ou le cas des
jeunes qui ont été arrêtés
je pense que les les analyses de fond le
confirmeront il y a quand même un défaut
éducatif majeur donc et là il y a pas eu
de sanctions il y a pas eu de sanction
on a posé nous la question de
conditionner les allocations sociales
qui sont théoriquement faites pour
l'éducatif quand il y a un défaut
d'éducation il y a une question j'ai vu
que même que le père de famille de Naël
alors qu'il y avait un défaut
d'éducation pendant des années il
s'intéressait à son fils quand il y a eu
le drame il a annoncé se porter partie
civile voilà donc là il y a quand même
quelque chose qui interroge c'est-à-dire
qu'il ne se sent pas concernés par ce
qui est arrivé avant que le DRAM arrive
il y a eu des 17 ans de défaillance
là-dessus je veux dire là il y a on me
parlait de l'école mais la la question
de la responsabilité parentale me semble
majeur et quand il y a une telle
défaillance il faut quand même se poser
la question sur les mécanismes de
responsabilisation je m'interroge quand
même sur à chaque fois que il y a des
événements de délinquance qui touchent
des mineurs
la droite parce que dans ce camp-là que
ça monte pose deux questions qui sont
toujours les mêmes est-ce qu'il faut
revoir l'ordonnance de 45 des mineurs et
puis est-ce qu'il faut supprimer les
allocations
ça fait 20 ans vous pouvez le
reconnaître ça fait 20 ans que vous que
vous proposez ça à chaque fois qu'on
parle de délinquance des mineurs et ça
n'arrange rien vous avez été au pouvoir
ça n'a pas baissé vous avez été au
pouvoir vous personnellement la droite a
été au pouvoir et si c'était si simple
si c'était si simple de mettre les
mineurs en prison comme le suggère le
rassemblement national on sait bien que
on va pas revenir sur l'école du crime
mais c'est pas c'est pas forcément
quelque chose qui favorise
il y a des centres duquel ferme il y a
des alternatives et les allocs des
parents
c'est la même chose parce que en gros
non mais ça ça revient à pénaliser les
petits frères les petites sœurs ça
revient à pénaliser les petits frères et
les petites sœurs vous pouvez pas dire
l'inverse si les parents ont moins de
moyens c'est les c'est c'est
ajouter de la misérable du ressentiment
allez
les difficultés de mise en œuvre mais
c'est pas parce qu'il y a des
difficultés avec la pose des questions
pour être le plus fin possible dans dans
dans le but d'obtenir une modification
du comportement parental qu'on doit
renoncer je veux dire il y a une
véritable problème avec des tranches
d'âge qui sont déstructurés qui n'ont
plus le sentiment d'appartenance et qui
sont livrés eux-mêmes et aujourd'hui il
y avait à l'époque à l'époque
Jean-Pierre Chevènement mis Center avait
parlé de sauvageons on a ce phénomène
aujourd'hui juste là encore le code
pénal prévoit des des
défaillances et le Code civil prévoit
que les parents le texte les textes
encore ils sont très peu appliqués la
sanction que vous êtes tous les maires
vous le disent quand ils ont des
dégradations enfin une compagnie ils ont
beau écrire procureur la sanction
derrière quand elle arrive quand elle
arrive c'est une monnaie et ça arrive
plusieurs mois de décalage quand ça
arrive mais les jeunes aujourd'hui ils
ont très bien compris intégré ça ils
vous rayonnaient alors toujours sur
cette question deux éléments sur ce que
le gouvernement propose en cette fin
d'après-midi le garde des sorry du pont
béréotype évoque l'idée d'envoyer un
flyer aux parents pour expliquer en
terme simple quels sont leurs
obligations à ceux qui les auraient
oubliés bon on peut on peut juger ça
vous dites ridicule anecdotique enfin je
vous donnerai la parole pour en parler
mais il y a aussi ce que propose le
porte-parole du gouvernement c'était
juste après le conseil des ministres
alors là on est beaucoup plus précis sur
ce que les parents devraient faire une
sorte de stage de responsabilisation
écoutons Olivier Véran il est
inacceptable il est impensable que des
jeunes adolescents parfois âgés de
seulement de 12 ans s'organise en bande
pour investir les villes à la nuit
tombée et pour se livrer à des scènes de
violence il est inacceptable pense que
des parents laissent faire ce type de
situation ainsi les parents seront mis
face à leur responsabilité avec des
amendes des stages de responsabilisation
parentale pour je le précise ceux qui ne
répondraient pas aux convocations dans
les procédures mettant en cause leur
enfant allez amour on vous apporte
encore entendu là-dessus Yann Chanel
ensuite on parle de la loi d'urgence de
la reconstruction donc une réponse
rapide là-dessus oui bah assez
rapidement on voit bien toutes ces
propositions c'est des écrans de fumée
ça va pas résoudre les problèmes de fond
je pense qu'on en a tous conscience
c'est pas très sérieux même quelque part
et envoyer la responsabilité aux parents
se déresponsabiliser finalement c'est ne
pas se responsabiliser soi-même en tant
que politique aux manettes ou
Gouvernement sur ce qui pourrait être
faire et qui est très politique parce
que le côté la société n'existe pas les
individus sont responsables ça c'est
faux on est tous connectés entre société
dans les cas en fonction des quartiers
des écoles auxquelles on a accès si vous
voulez éduquer moi je suis prêt à parler
d'éduquer le les écoles qui sont dans
les quartiers sont des écoles qui sont
souvent fuites par de nombreuses
familles et qui concentre les
difficultés et logiquement si on veut
que l'égalité soit partout là où il y a
le plus de difficultés c'est là où il
faut mettre le plus de moyens on a
souvent
et trop de jeunes des enseignants qui
sont pas expérimentés et qu'il faudrait
peut-être même doubler le salaire parce
qu'ils vont dans des quartiers où on
enseignement que dans le 16e
arrondissement de Paris donc
automatiquement non il faudrait il
faudrait justement en faire une vraie
priorité il y a eu les écoles voilà ça
c'est très bien dédoublements des
doublesment les écoles maternes mais
faudrait l'élargir à beaucoup plus que
ça oui c'est bien ça c'est une bonne
chose effectivement mais c'est petit on
touche pas à l'ensemble justement de
l'éducation quand on dédoube juste
quelques classes de primaires il faut
aller beaucoup ça mérite un débat en soi
et il sera passionnant sur effectivement
ce qu'on peut changer en termes
d'éducation comme promis on va terminer
ce débat sur la reconstruction Samia de
chien vous pouvez nous rejoindre bonsoir
Samia bienvenue à vous comment
reconstruire rapidement ce qui a été
détruit ces derniers jours une sénatrice
a des propositions concrètes pour aller
plus Sophie prima sénatrice des Yvelines
veut accélérer la reconstruction des
bâtiments publics elle a déposé une
proposition de loi pour qu'on puisse
aller plus vite dans la réflexion des
mairies des écoles des commissariats qui
ont été dégradés ces derniers jours son
idée c'est de permettre aux élus locaux
de déroger à certaines règles de
construction des élus locaux qui sont
parfois désemparés face à l'ampleur de
la tâche c'est ce que nous a rapporté
Sophie prima regardez devant les visites
que nous avons fait avec le président
anarchie en particulier dans les
Yvelines ce week-end et lundi on avait
le même sentiment vous savez que quand
Notre Dame de Paris a brûlé un espèce de
sentiment de découragement et de pertes
qu'on ressentait notamment chez les élus
locaux et puis des questions qui étaient
comment je fais ma rentrée en septembre
comment j'accueille les enfants dans les
crèches qu'on brûlées etc et comment je
fais avec le service public sa
proposition de loi s'inspire donc à
l'entendu de ce qui a été fait après
l'incendie de Notre-Dame de Paris en
2019 on avait voté une loi d'exception
pour réussir à reconstruire en 5 ans la
cathédrale attend donc pour les Jeux
Olympiques de Paris concrètement ça
changerait quoi en termes de
construction alors Sophie il prima
propose d'asses d'assouplir certaines
règles c'est-à-dire pouvoir déroger au
plan locaux d'urbanisme elle propose
aussi de pouvoir passer un marché sans
publicité ni concurrence préalable par
exemple à une mairie qui voudrait lancer
des travaux pour réparer un bâtiment
dégradé pourrait embaucher directement
une entreprise du BTP sans passer par
les procédures classiques d'appel
d'offres et puis elle propose enfin que
toutes les dépenses des collectivités
engagées pour ces travaux d'urgence
puisse être intégralement compensé par
l'État ou d'autres collectivités comme
les régions ou les départements pourquoi
et bien parce que aujourd'hui ce n'est
pas possible les subventions publiques
ne peuvent pas financer plus de 80% d'un
projet alors on sait que quand Emmanuel
Macron a reçu les 250 maires de villes
frappées par par des émeutes il a fait
lui-même une proposition de la d'urgence
ça veut dire quoi va y avoir de loi
alors c'est peu probablement a priori ce
sera plutôt soit l'un soit l'une soit
l'autre la proposition de loi de Sophie
primal le mérite d'être déjà écrite déjà
déposé alors que le projet de loi du
gouvernement pour l'instant on ne sait
pas encore vraiment précisément ce qu'il
contient et puis surtout ça paraît quand
même compliqué de le faire adopter d'ici
la pose estivale comme l'a annoncé
aujourd'hui Olivier Véran pourquoi parce
qu'un projet de loi quand il vient du
gouvernement il doit d'abord faire
l'objet d'une étude d'impact d'un avis
du Conseil d'État alors que un texte qui
vient des sénateurs ou des députés d'un
parlementaire et bien ça peut aller
beaucoup plus vite parce que ces étapes
là elles ne sont pas nécessaires alors
est-ce que le gouvernement va choisir de
soutenir le texte de sénatrice Sophie
prima pour gagner du temps plutôt que de
présenter sa propre loi il y a peu de
chances que ça arrive puisque l'exécutif
n'aura probablement pas envie de perdre
la main au profit de la droite
sénatoriale on sait en tout cas que
Gérard Larcher Emmanuel Emmanuel Macron
ont échangé sur le sujet lundi quand ils
se sont rencontrés merci beaucoup Samia
François Patriat il faut s'il y a une
partie du travail qui a été fait donc
profitons de la politique en
l'occurrence ce que je crois c'est que
dans les positions qui sont faites à
défaut de dire que on peut déjà
raccourcir les délais pour les appels
d'offres on peut raccourcir pense qu'au
moins parce que pas interroger aux
règles de la concurrence ça ouvrirait
d'autres choses moi ce que je pense
c'est que là il faut s'inspirer de
toutes les bonnes volontés et de toutes
les bonnes propositions s'il y a dans la
dans la PPL de Sophie primanin chose que
le gouvernement peut reprendre qu'il en
discute s'il veut y ajouter quelque
chose lui-même le gouvernement peut très
bien prendre une PPL dit bah voilà dans
les propositions que vous faites on l'a
vu on l'a vu par exemple dans ce qui
concerne la protection des élus j'ai le
sentiment aujourd'hui que le
gouvernement va faire une grande réunion
où il va prendre toutes les propositions
de tous les partis pour le protection
des élus là on peut le faire de la même
façon le gouvernement s'il souhaite
aller vite je n'ai pas son calendrier
peut très bien s'inspirer de ce qui est
proposé aujourd'hui apporter ces
éléments lui-même qui sont peut-être des
avancés aussi et d'aboutir à quelque
chose de plus rapide votre avis à mon
avis c'est que les maires qui ont été
touchés sont dans tellement désemparés
que on doit vraiment trouver un moyen y
compris par la loi donc de faciliter
toutes les procédures qui sont
extrêmement lourdes dans le C c'est deux
trois ans donc on peut pas attendre deux
trois ans pour reconstruire tout ce qui
a été tout ce qui a été détruit beaucoup
d'écoles de la proposition de loi que
j'ai consigné personnellement c'est
vraiment de tenir compte de la
exceptionnel pour avoir une procédure
exceptionnelle le temps de
reconstruction et pour permettre de
retrouver du service public qui va faire
défaut dès la rentrée pour les écoles
Ian centrale Emmanuel Macron il est
auprès des élus locaux lors des crises
pas suffisamment entre les crises est-ce
que vous dites ça non c'est quelqu'un
qui connaît peu le mandat des Lucas
c'est un fait et il l'a jamais été
lui-même il a été élu très jeune sans
avoir de parcours politique auparavant
il y a eu des malentendus récurrents
avec les élus c'est le moins qu'on
puisse dire puisque c'est c'est quelque
chose qui connaît pas qui est plus
inquiétant parce que être élu local
c'est pas juste le fait d'être élu c'est
que vous êtes en contact constamment nos
compatriotes au plus près du terrain et
c'est peut-être malheureusement ce qui
manque au président de la République
c'est que lui il n'a jamais eu ce
contact
plus près du terrain au plus près des
gens qui souffrent concernant le sujet
que nous évoquons ça peut être un sujet
consensuel bien évidemment nous vous
souhaitons tous que ça aille plus vite
qu'on puisse construire rapidement par
contre faut garantir la probité les
marchés publics si ça a été mis en place
c'est aussi pour garantir qui est pas de
malversation ou autre donc faut quand
même être vigilant là-dessus mais bien
évidemment participera tous à l'effort
national pour pouvoir reconstruire au
plus vite et on fait ça sur le lien
entre Emmanuel Macron et les élus locaux
dans la République et j'en ai connu 6
qui est autant reçu et rencontré les
élus la grande itinérance dans le grand
débat le Président il a montré il a
montré sans papiers Kobé connaissait les
problèmes des deux locaux chaque année
pour le congrès des mers il reçoit 1000
maires analysée il vient de recevoir des
maires ici il va pouvoir les mers sur le
territoire donc je peux pas laisser dire
aujourd'hui que pendant la réception
je l'ai vu chaque fois qu'il est né dans
les côtes partout dans les dans les
départements dans les territoires et la
rencontrer les élus bon je peux pas dire
aujourd'hui qui est qui est un
désintérêt ou une méfiance du l'égard de
chef de l'été merci beaucoup merci à
tous d'avoir participé à ce débat je
vous dis évidemment à bientôt sur sur
public